This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MuteEnglish
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
In this programme, we'll be hearing a new story linked to the nature versus nurture debate,
not concerning a human, but a rhinoceros.
The extremely rare Northern white rhino of East Africa was on the brink of extinction
when the second to last living male, Sunny, died in 2014, leaving behind two females,
Nagine and Fattu, the last living creatures of their species.
Conservationist started an artificial breeding programme, using eggs from the females and sperm from
Sunny to produce an embryo, an unborn animal in the very early stages of development.
Recently, there's been a new development in the story, but before we hear more, it's time for my
quiz question. The name rhinoceros comes from the ancient Greek, but what exactly does it mean?
Is it A, thick skin, B, horned nose, or C, small eye?
Ooh, that's a tricky one because rhinos have all three.
Okay, I'll guess A, thick skin.
Okay, Sam will find out later. Now let's get back to the story of those precious northern rhino
embryos. Well, the good news is that so far five embryos have been produced. They're being frozen
until they can be implanted in southern rhinos. The Northern species is more common cousin.
Conservationist Thomas Hildebrand runs the Rhino breeding programme. He spoke to BBC World
Services Science in Action, who asked him whether the embryos were genetically from the northern species.
Absolutely right, that's a hybrid that's pure northern rhinos embryos, which were generated
with the desire breeding partner, SUNY, who died in 2014. So we have embryos which have a very
high quality. There's no inbreeding effect on these embryos, and it is so important to
make the next step to transfer these embryos because we can preserve life biologically
material in liquid nitrogen, but what we can't do, we can't preserve social knowledge. And
therefore we need desperately a calf on the ground so that these two existing northern rhinos can
teach the new calf how to behave as a northern right rhino. Having genetically pure embryos
prevents the birth of hybrids, animals that have been bred from two different species.
It's also important the embryos have no inbreeding. Breeding of a young animal from two closely
related parents, because this can cause disease. Fortunately, Thomas and his team have preserved
five healthy and genetically pure northern rhino embryos in liquid nitrogen. But while they can
preserve nature, what Thomas's team can't provide is nurture. The social knowledge that a young
northern rhino or calf can only learn from other northern rhinos. And since Najin and Fattu,
the last remaining northern rhinos on earth, are getting old, the race is on to breed a young
rhino calf before they die. The good news for the survival of the northern white rhino is that
experiments to implant the delicate embryos in southern rhinos have been successful.
Here's Thomas Hilderand again, talking about these recent experiments with BBC World Service
Program Science in Action. We will for sure not wait until this pregnancy is completed,
because it takes 16 months for a full pregnancy in a rhino to us. So if this embryo implants,
and we can see that in ultrasound and form a nice placenta, that is the goal for us to proceed
with the next step on the northern white rhino embryos. Normally, it takes 16 months for a female
rhino to complete her pregnancy, the state in which a woman or female animal has a baby developing
inside her. But in the case of the northern rhino, the race is on to birth calves who can learn the
rhino rules of social behaviour from Antinagin and Granny Fattu while they're still alive.
Which is why conservationists are monitoring the pregnancy using ultrasound, a procedure using
sound waves to create images of internal body parts, or in this case, growing rhino babies.
It's an unusual episode in the ongoing nature versus nurture debate.
And hopefully a big step towards restoring the northern white rhino population,
so that future generations get to see these magnificent creatures with their thick skin,
horn nose and... And small eyes, Neil. So what was the answer to your question?
Yes, I asked you what the name rhinoceros meant. What did you say, Sam?
I guessed it was a thick skin. Was I right?
Well, rhino certainly do have thick skin, but their name actually comes from the Greek meaning
horned nose. Hmm, well luckily I've got a thick skin too, so I won't take it personally.
Let's have another look at the vocabulary we've learned, starting with embryo,
an unborn animal or human, still inside its mother's womb.
A hybrid is an animal or plant that has been bred from two different species.
Inbreeding is when a young animal is born from closely related parents.
A calf is the name for the young of several large mammals including cows, elephants and whales,
as well as rhinos. Pregnancy means being pregnant or growing a baby inside you.
And finally, ultrasound is used to see internal organs or a baby developing inside a woman.
And that's all from this species saving edition of Sixth-Vide English.
Goodbye. Bye-bye.